[Musique]
alors bon soir bonjour à la planète
c'est un thème canada on dirait que
montréal il est 11h15
on a décidé d'ajuster notre ère de dents
volé à 11h15 tous les vendredis prendre
quatre minutes pour se reposer un peu
semaine difficile et puis ensuite lancer
cette émission qui est vu partout à
travers le monde
voici nos animateurs invité cette
semaine marie claude simard
bonjourbonjour mark pagani de la section
anglaise du canada réserve
bonjour et puis allez chantal tandem qui
a accepté venir faire prendre un siège
aux seizièmes comme sauber avec plaisir
stéphane ex écouter ensemble vous pensez
peut-être que nous allons pas lire
parler de la saint patrick
vous avez les couleurs du jour c'est pas
ils soulèvent initiale du tout comment
on fait pour découvrir dessus des
missions vous le savez alors dites-le
parce que c'est pas de la règle
aujourd'hui des images on va aller voir
concours cinq images vidéos qu on
présente ça on regarde ça tous ensemble
c'est un sujet je vous dis qu'il est de
l'intérêt universel qu'est voilà
premières images nous ajuster les fonds
de cellulaires dans les salles de classe
non
c'est en partie ce lot situé en partie
là pour les chiens par c'est un parti
nouvelles technologies en partie 5
animal j'avais toujours pas saisi le
sujet 5e et la 6e on va vous à faire une
sixième sens l'essence c'est ce qu'on a
programmé un oui aujourd'hui
l'absolution nommé alors nous notre
émission va se désagréger deux heureux
alors vous allez tous une idée de ckoi
l'absence programmée vous allez
découvrir plusieurs formes
vous allez aussi vous poser la question
est ce que ça existe vraiment exactement
puisque et des spécialistes qui disent
non pas vraiment c'est pas vraiment
organisé mais ça se produit et ou dix
fois
peut-être qu'il ya des gars qui a des
gens qui la vie aurait du complot exact
alors si vous allez sur le web grâce
yanis je vais vous mettre dans le bain
avec une petite histoire ou juste pour
vous montrer à quoi ça ressemble
apparemment l'absolu obsolescence dite
programmé
c'est au niveau des téléphones
cellulaires ça vous est déjà arrivé
d'avoir un bon bon téléphone il ya
quelque chose qui est brisée mais ça va
coûter combien pour le remplacer ça va
coûter trois fois plus cher que le coût
toujours trop chères ou la réparer donc
on la pire des heures on vous dit que
c'est même pas réparable j'avais
perceuse avec une batterie
le battery avant menée après quelques
années ça fait défaut tu veux acheter un
autre batterie qui coûte plus cher que
d'acheter l'ensemble l'unité ensemble
donc j'ai été obligé d'acheter une unité
ensemble au lieu d'avoir acheté juste
simple batelli qui écoutent l'ensemble
coûte moins cher qu'une de remplaçant
dès lors et s'est retrouvé au dépotoir
c'est cela je pense que c'est une
stratégie imaginée pour inciter les gens
à consommer tout le temps à ça on veut
créer la société d'hyperconsommation où
les gens seront obligés d'âge est tout
le temps à acheter peut-être que c'est
seulement à la fin de plusieurs jamais
qu'on a des téléphones cellulaires puis
là on se rend compte qu'à chaque fois on
n'est pas capable de finir son compteur
là je vous montre une solution avant de
parler de crise il y en a une à montréal
il suffit de faire jouer ses doigts dans
les pages jaunes
pagesjaunes si l'on trouve les infos et
on la retrouve très rapidement zone
accroc ça existe depuis au moins quatre
ou cinq ans mais vous connaissez cette
entreprise sont les seuls moyens accroc
pour ceux qui sont accros des toutes les
technologies qui veut le faire réparer
leur objet voici un reportage un extrait
de reportage de radio canada présentée
par olivier bachand à notre antenne
récemment fin ça fait quatre ans qu'on a
présenté sa une entreprise existe
toujours et le problème ou si on regarde
ça ensemble on se met dans le bain des
missions
sauf la colle qui est autour de l'écran
caché entre la peinture pour pouvoir
accéder à l'intérieur de l'appareil
ouvrir une tablette électronique pour la
réparer n'est pas de tout repos
selon william dubé les fabricants le
font exprès et les problèmes les plus
banales deviennent compliqués à régler
en une pile qui est défectueuse qui
pourrait très sympa changer un coût très
bas
l'appareil ne s'ouvre pas en tant que
telle n'est pas de vis on ouvre on n'a
rien françois delost répare des
électroménagers depuis plus de 20 ans il
affirme aussi que les appareils se brise
plus rapidement qu'auparavant dans les
années sont les us 80 les appareils
c'est vrai que ça dure et 20 et 30 ans 5
mois et 2 sans couper sans d'admettre
que nous devons changer du du métal pour
du plastique des pratiques qui entraîne
non seulement des coûts pour les
consommateurs mais aussi pour
l'environnement 140 mille tonnes de
produits électroniques sont jetés chaque
année au canada alors à travers notre
discussion aujourd'hui on ajoute une
petite boule de plaisir
en face de vous se trouve la grosse
bouée de l'émission et il ya trois jeux
à l'émission à chaque jeu vous risquez
de perdre un certain nombre de boules y
en a cent à perdre au total pour le
premier tour c'est 20 boules
vous êtes prêtre le jeu à lormont alors
on parle beaucoup des téléphones
quand on se débarrasse de ça ça finit
par coûter cher voici la question
la fabrication d'un seul téléphone
intelligent génère environ ont je veux
dire 32 kg de co2 pour la fabrication
d'accord 32 kg c'est quand même ça pèse
pas lourd mais ces 32 kg et cette
fabrication requiert selon vous convier
des kilos de matières premières
est-ce que c'est à 3 kg de matières
premières est ce que ces bébés 13 kg de
matières premières est ce que c'est
c'est 33 kg de matières premières ou
est-ce que c'est d aucune de ces
réponses 20 boules à perdre commencez
par vous ouais ou encore un téléphone
cellulaire intelligent 13 b pour vous
c'est pour marie-claude moi j'irai avec
1 à 3 kg seulement
n'est ce pas lui qui le fasse pas la
bonne réponse et des vous perdez tous
vos cool c'est aussi 70 kg de matière
première et jusqu'à 20 60 métaux
différents 60 au téléphone c'est pas
réparable pour ça je sais que ça coûte
et on a vendu l'an dernier au palais
dernier oui l'an dernier je pense un peu
plus d'un milliard ailleurs le monde et
il ya maintenant presque autant de
téléphones sévère qui a d'êtres humains
sur la planète toutes les marques
confondues
oui oui même celle des martiens alors
voici je voudrais maintenant vous
apporter des solutions à vos
interrogations vous poser je vois les
questions qui se vantent spi dans votre
tête
voici votre avis qui se trouve sur skype
aujourd'hui et il s'agit de quelqu'un
qui est très recommandé qui a une
expérience en cette matière au canada
i la bête robineau bonjour bonjour est
ce que vous ne voyez bien oui oui je
vous vois très bien
bon on est combien la vie est professeur
au département de mark était une
université du québec à montréal donc pas
loin d'ici en principe lorsque vous
enseigner quel est votre niveau
d'expertisé au niveau de l'obsolescence
et de l'obsolescence programmée qui est
un kit une problème augment qui est
augmentée si vous voulez par rapport à
ce qu'on discute aujourd'hui
alors moi je suis donc professeur
département marketing comme vous l'avez
dit est aussi membre de l'observatoire
de la consommation responsable et en
partenariat avec la
l'entreprise équiterre nous avons
réalisé en janvier 2018
une enquête auprès de 2200 de répondant
de la population canadienne sur ce sujet
là précisément voilà bon est ce que vous
pourriez y répondre à ma question
seulement un peu pop l'éducation parce
que j'ai fait beaucoup de recherches là
dessus cette semaine j'ai pas eu la
réponse est ce que ça existe
l'obsolescence programmée quelque chose
qui est planifié la minceur des corps
par les fabricants alors ça c'est très
délicat comme sujet effectivement on a
beaucoup de difficulté à trouver des
preuves tangibles que les fabricants
rendrait obsolète de façon volontaire
les produits qu'ils mettent sur le
marché
par contre ce que révèle notre étude
c'est qu'il existe une obsolescence
relative
c'est à dire que les objets fonctionne
encore et pourtant ils sont mis au rebut
et ça ça vient du fait principalement du
comportement des consommateurs
donc c'est quelque chose à sur lequel il
faut sensibiliser les individus parce
que notre étude si vous voulez souligne
que les consommateurs n'ont pas
réellement conscience du rôle qu'ils
jouent dans ce phénomène de
l'obsolescence alors qu'ils sont partie
prenante intégrante du fait de changer
son téléphone alors qu'ils fonctionnent
encore ou alors de décider de ne pas
réparer comme l'on dit vos chroniqueurs
tout à l'heure leur d'outillage parce
que pour x et x raisons voilà la semaine
dernière avait fait une émission sur les
compagnies aériennes et les nouveaux
droits des passagers en disant que la
faute n'était pas celle des compagnies
mais des des voyageurs qui voyageait
trop c'est pas exactement ce que vous et
a expliqué de nuancer commandant comment
donner un exemple dans le comportement
de quelqu'un qui a un téléphone
cellulaire et qui prend pas conscience
de du du gâchis voilà mais en fait si
vous voulez l'obsolescence cette fameuse
obsolescence relative qui fait que
l'individu met de côté par exemple son
téléphone on a tout chez nous un tiroir
plein d'anciens téléphones on n'utilise
plus et pourtant on se dit ça peut
toujours servir mais ce pas donc
c'est une réelle problématique sociétale
et environnementale parce que c'est
plein de matières qui est pas
revalorisés donc cette fois cette
obsolescence relative elle a trois
elle vient de trois raisons la première
c'est tout simplement fonctionnelles et
technologiques comme l'a dit ça
fonctionne moins bien il faut essayer de
réparer voilà ou alors si vous voulez
c'est le fait d'avoir mis d'avoir mis
une nouvelle version de mise à jour dans
son téléphone et le fait que le
téléphone pour ralentissent vous voyez
ensuite on a là l'obsolescence scellier
relative liée à la question économique
avec la question justement la
réparabilité et du rapport qualité prix
que ça que ça génère est ce que c'est
vraiment intéressant d'un point de vue
économique de faire réparer
voilà aujourd'hui c'est pas tout le
temps à trancher la question est pas
tout tout le temps tranché et le service
après-vente souvent n'est pas un n'est
pas pas d'assez bonne qualité si vous
voulez ou ne va pas offrir un service
rapide ce qui fait que l'individu elle
n'a pas envie d'attendre un mois et demi
pour retrouver son blender qui
reviennent la réparation dont il va en
racheter un est en fête et enfin
finalement il ya la dimension
psychologique lié à tout ça c'est le
critère esthétique l'effet de mode
le fait que mon ami et acheter le
dernier iphone à la mode fait que je
vais peut-être avoir envie moi aussi
d'avoir ce dernier téléphone là et donc
trois dimensions ces trois éléments
jouent sur la perception de
l'obsolescence de l'individu par rapport
à ces appareils effet que les individus
vont changer alors que leur objet
fonctionne encore ou alors qu'il serait
si vous voulez réparable voilà trois
formes d'obsolescence
bah oui en fait jamais posé la question
mais je pense qu'elle a donné une
réponse partielle mais je la poste même
durant votre étude
quels sont les types de
motivation qui sont revenus le plus
souvent chez les consommateurs ce qui
concerne la mise aux poubelles
d'appareils tout à fait fonctionnel
c'est ça c'est le fait que si vous
voulez ils ont du mal à savoir
mais ce qui pourrait en faire aussi où
est ce qu'ils pouvaient ce qui pourrait
les faire réparer
on note un réel besoin de moi de
d'informer les consommateurs sur toutes
les possibilités qu'ils ont les offres
de reprise de certains opérateurs
téléphoniques par exemple et voilà les
possibilités qu'il existe par exemple
des endroits comme le répètent café où
vous pouvez amener vos petits
électroménagers afin de leur donner une
seconde vie avec l'autre des questions
mais j'ai une question
en attendant on a vu des images de tous
ces déchets électroniques ailier des
places comme dans le tiers monde où il
ya des travailleurs qui essaient de
tirer quelques matières assez importante
l'offre par exemple l'argent d'autres
matériaux de questions que j'ai est ce
qu'on sait à quel pourcentage on recycle
ses après l'or et est ce que les effets
sur l'environnement sont en effet plus
nocif que de les laisser dans un
dépotoir
c'est très difficile à quantifier on n'a
pas effectivement de donner là dessus
sur couple effectivement comme vous
l'avez de souligner souvent sa part dans
des pays
et là on perd tout contrôle sur les
volumes les quantités la transformation
cependant quand même on arrive à
souligner le fait que pour certains
hormis les téléphones intelligents ou là
il ya des matériaux rares ou sega c'est
complexe
pour les autres petits appareils
électroménagers ménages et le recyclage
est faisable et leur redonner une vie
c'est tout à fait réaliste certains dans
certaines entreprises par exemple la
société seb qui est une société
française d'électroménager peut-être que
vous avez un appareil chez vous de cette
marque là offre des garanties de 10 ans
justement pour faire en sorte de
sensibiliser les consommateurs par
rapport à ces questions là et faire en
sorte qu'ils n'hésitent pas à réparer à
utiliser les services après-vente voyez
moi je suis d'accord avec vous que c'est
vraiment le consommateur qui finalement
prend la décision bon ok je vais acheter
mon ancien téléphone je vais en acheter
un nouveau c'est vrai que c'est sa
décision c'est sa responsabilité mais il
ya quand même une conspiration parce
qu'on est vraiment pas informé à l'achat
de toutes les options possibles on voit
quand même que les entreprises font pas
des efforts pour dire écoutez dans les
trois prochaines années s'il arrive quoi
que ce soit de téléphone on le reprend
nous on sait quoi faire où on voit qu'il
ya pas de volonté non plus du côté des
entreprises moche je pouvais je
souhaitais un croc qui me semble que
quand même un peu de l'obsolescence
programmée dans le sens là en fait si
vous voulez c'est vrai que nous sommes à
la traîne ici au québec en europe et
surtout en france l'association halte à
l'obsolescence programmée qui s'appelle
up vient de sortir un livre blanc est
effectivement dans ce livre blanc il
donne 50 mesures pour donner un cadre
législatif et réglementaire favorable
pour justement et d allonger la durée de
vie des petits appareils électroménagers
qui sont les plus musique conte
l'environnement et donne des idées au mr
et des indices de durabilité qu'on
pourrait apposer si vous savez sur les
produits responsabilités et pardon les
fabricants à ces questions là et
pourquoi pas les faire participer à un
fonds qui permettrait de communiquer sur
ces questions encadré plus la publicité
permettre aussi d'allonger la garantie
voiliers et oraux puisqu'on puis en
avant la thur côté canadien ya certaines
initiatives qui se mettent et
québécoises qui se met en place
l'association hope est aussi présente
sur le territoire québécois
et petit à petit on voit quand même des
mouvements citoyens avec des plateformes
ou des modèles collaboratif qui se met
en place sur internet qui permettent aux
consommateurs quand même de s'informer
voilà et voilà ça va peut-être faire
pencher les choses envers des mesures
législatives
un petit peu plus
un petit peu plus encadrante afin que si
vous voulez les entreprises soient plus
sensibles à ça et participe plus à
contourner ces questions quoi et en ce
qui concerne la stabilité de ces
messages là pensez vous que les
entreprises soient totalement ouverte
disposer vraiment à prolonger la durée
de vie de leurs appareils
parce que j'imagine que derrière il ya
toute une stratégie marketing faux-pas
ce pas penser qu'on va changer les
modèles d'affaires et échanges est
évident que c'est compliqué que c'est
long cependant il faut pas revenir alors
faire à faire en sorte que les
entreprises aussi un rôle à jouer dans
la société on arrive au jeu pendant un
modèle social là qui commence à être
sous tension aujourd'hui c'est là quand
même c'est un jour important
le 15 mars il ya des manifestations
partout dans le monde pour la journée
pour la protection du climat
il ya une prise de conscience et sociale
à l'égard des questions
environnementales pour une prise en
compte des caisses de ces questions-là
plus dans la société donc les
entreprises qui vont aller dans ce genre
de questions qui vont réfléchir à leur
modèle d'affaires réfléchir la
communication regardez patagonien c'est
une entreprise qui vous communique en
disant de nice jacques est échue dorny
dit d'accord donc on va vers des choses
sens pour plus qu être plus
consciencieux plus responsable dans la
société que l'on veut donner aux futures
générations donc moi j'y crois
soyons optimistes
merci beaucoup madame robineau nous
avoir prêté votre votre savoir et nous
avoir fait part des commentaires des
consommateurs ici même au québec sur
cette question qui nous touche tous qui
nous affecte tous
en cette journée où on souligne le
climat il ya des jeunes les jeux promis
à moins qu'à montréal
après 150 même pas aujourd'hui vers une
donc on a précédé mouvement on est
toujours un peu à l'avancé si merci au
cou elisabeth et m'a fait plaisir
à bientôt alors c'est elisabeth robineau
professeur au département marketing
université du québec à montréal
faut dire qu'il ya des alpes harnais des
initiatives citoyennes qui pourrait
déboucher sur des initiatives politiques
il ya eu une en ontario il ya un député
qui au je vous parle abondamment
que diriez-vous de perdre 30 autres
boules vous avez déjà perdu tout ce vin
bull 2e jeu démission alors voici
on en a parlé elle en a parlé donc
c'était un peu comme si vous écoutez le
professeur vous devriez avoir la réponse
maintenant aux tests on l'a bien écouter
qu'il ya plusieurs formes d'obsolescence
convient 3 3 très bien c'est pas la
question mais trois très bien alors aux
benjamins daniela non j'ai rien perdu
non plus mais vous avez puisqu'elle
cette façon non scientifique elle a
vulgarisé d'affaires sachant qu'il voit
si il ya plusieurs formes de ses
licences comment appelle-t-on le type
d'obsolescence qui consiste à présenter
en peu de temps aux consommateurs un
nouveau produit vanté comme étant
beaucoup peter formant et désirable que
l'ancien le précédent et ce à travers
une campagne publicitaire
ça c'est de l'obsolescence madame vas-y
c'est le troisième type d'obsolescence
et cas d'après moi le premier en tout
cas est ce qu on appelle ça
l'obsolescence automatique d'un
mouvement un produit c'est automatique
on va vouloir faire remplacer d'ici un
mois
est ce qu on appelle ça l'obsolescence
technique votre téléphone ni pub on vous
saviez pas mais il est plus bon pour en
acheter un nouveau
est-ce que c'est l'obsolescence
esthétique regardez le nouveau modèle
avec la cagnotte éthiques
vous pensez vous oui ok est-ce que c'est
l'obsolescence méthodique
esthétiquement j'ai cru entendre le beau
père la musique analogique technologique
b b sans canne a dit el cheikh par
n'était rien à voir cette technique a
soufflé hier technique moi je persiste
faisait esthétique alcine tout j'ai
entendu le concept esthétique et oui
j'adopte pour l'esthétique aussi
l'esthétique vous suivez les premiers
classe d'école pas mal après une
première de classe oui mais pas tout le
temps pas tout
alors bonne réponse
elle conserve ses 30 ball qui a dit
esthétique également vous conservez
votre en boule ajouté vous avez perdu un
moule c'est ça c'est l'absolue sens
esthétique aussi connu comme
psychologique
oui au culturel parce que dans certains
pays ou faire remplacer votre téléphone
celui-là c'est peut-être moins important
que vous faire remplacer la vache sacrée
fautes qu'on se bouge non mais elle a
quel âge a pas l'air de souffrir
d'obsolescence elle allait faire une
bruit quand même mais le sort blessé
mais pour la réparer à sa fin un petit
bruit ça prendrait vraiment ça coûterait
trop cher
ça date de gier su ça quand j'ai
emménagé dans ma nouvelle maison en 2010
je pense que c'est à peu près de l'a9 en
99 ans et sa maman est un jeu là j'avais
pas une vidéo vous présenter we vidéo de
niro 4 va vous présenter là quelques
secondes et 6 2 enquête réalisée par
radio-canada quatre années de différence
accord la première c'est 2014 la
deuxième c'est 2018 pour vous montrer
car pas grand chose qui a changé dans
l'obsolescence dans le fait que les
techniques et qu'on peut pas réparer
malheureusement votre appareil et si si
on peut la réparer ça va vous coûter
très cher
[Musique]
notre pièce à conviction un iphone 4
dans le bouton d'allumage fait défaut
le lieu du crime 3 apple store ceux de
montréal brossard et québec
nous sommes allés au genuis devoirs de
chacun des établissements avec une
caméra cachée
chaque fois voici ce qu'on nous a
répondu
je m'affaire
jali pas faire fonctionner le ton
la solution dans ce que si le bouton
m
au chum m
ses chances se servir
il
[Musique]
en septembre dernier une équipe de la
bbc s'est rendu avec une caméra cachée
dans une boutique apple de toronto
l'objectif faire réparer un ordinateur
parce que l'écran ne s'allume plus chez
à paul l'employé diagnostic une
infiltration d'eau nécessitant le
remplacement de plusieurs pièces
importantes
montant de la facture 1200 dollars soit
le prix d'un ordinateur neuf avant de
faire les réparations le même ordinateur
avec et confier un réparateur
indépendance en ouvrant l'ordinateur le
technicien réalise qu'une petite
languette métallique et pillent et qu'il
suffit de la redresser pour rétablir le
courant entre la batterie et le rétro
éclairage de l'écran
il aura suffi de deux minutes pour
régler le problème alors je pense qu'un
à une obsolescence quelque part
programmé des vies c'est parce que
beaucoup des 6es à ce moment là pas
moyen de les ouvrir maintenant ils sont
ces lignes c'est ça il y en avait qui
utilise un séchoir à cheveux pour
desceller alors je dis on sait pas on
peut faire ça aux appareils
électroniques ont donc on suggérait tout
le monde utilise et enfin j'ai quand
même un problème louisiane et ses deux
plans de chez moi j'ai toujours dit ça
casse c'est pas grave je voulais vous
amener sur le site web de radio-canada
international parce que nous on a
beaucoup de plaisir on discutera le
mirage de ces sujets là mais on n'a pas
le temps tous présentés on a une mission
qui est après tout sur le web
c'est un peu comme la télévision et une
nuits de temps ces programmes est alors
nous sur notre vidéo d'une grosse un
coup sûr on vous amène source
à quoi ça ressemble aujourd'hui la page
web qui accompagne cette émission de tam
tam et on regarde ça ensemble et voir il
ya cinq reportages pense qu'un à 5 cette
semaine qui traitent du sujet de
l'obsolescence
c'est pas nouveau on vous le dit c'est
un vieux problème alors là c'est là
c'est la page découvrez nos archives sur
le sujet alors voyez le mot
c'est l'essence de l'instance ouais
c'est un mot clic qui vient revient
plusieurs fois que l'image de la pôle
revient aussi à ses frais quand on met
l'accent sur le troisième
et ça coûte c'est facile et ça coûte
moins cher de quoi je voudrais compris
mais vous allez voir le set cet homme là
c'est un député ontarien je l'avais
promis nous en parler michael coteaux
qui a présenté un projet de loi privé
vient faire ça il ya un mois oui ça
ferait quand même en tario les citoyens
seraient protégés par les yeux plutôt
savait pas où aller
exaltant mais au moment de la vente on
vous dirait voici non seulement vous
allez savoir où aller si un problème et
on voit vous identifier les dons on va
avoir jochen fly explicative et les
manuels aussi en cas de de pinte de
défauts mais c'est vous aurez accès à ce
que parce qu'ils font c'est qu'ils
cachent très souvent le manuel mann ou
technique de l'appareil
mais en fait y en a plus maintenant il
faut que tu es sur l'internet pour le
pour le voir sur l'internet il donne
plus avec lui mais des fois il ne cache
pas le voir donc savoir par où wade
c'est eden d'un encadrement et
règlements au québec vous êtes protégé
également par la loi sur la protection
du consommateur
j'ai pas le texte précis mais ça dit que
vous avez droit de jouir pendant un
certain une certaine durée raisonnable
de votre de votre bien oui donc célèbre
jeu pendant neuf mois sakassou en un an
et demi un réfrigérateur brise mon dieu
que tu attendais nous est floue comme
comme loin il faudrait quand même un peu
la moderniser car en intégrant cadence
mais ça sert à ça date de quand un peu
près ça fait longtemps je dois faire les
années de les appareils sont de plus en
plus sophistiqués chères d'où la
nécessité vraiment de procéder à un
toilettage de cette nouvelle fait de
charger des téléphones aussi souvent
c'est peut-être avec les nouvelles
modèles qui coûtent une fortune garde à
ckoi de nouvelles choses client qui est
1000 $ aux messins soir le téléphone
juste pour des téléphones qu'on va
peut-être pas le jeu l'échangé aussi
rapidement je passais pour le 1 %
on parle beaucoup de gens
du 1 % qui possède la fortune de toute
l'humanité des fanatiques de la
chronique d'une nouvelle affaire
qu'est ce qu'on va faire une émission
sur le 1% très bien tout ça que ça monte
moins 702 bon écoutez vous savez à
chaque émission avant qu'on mette fin à
nos activités
bien avant qu'on mette une hausse moins
de dix minutes je vous propose de
deviner avec moi l'image la semaine et
elles n'ont pas tout de suite où il
habita musique merci beaucoup aux
mondiaux sont à temps que si l'état des
routes la régie vous soit impeccable
donc même si pour la compagnie s'est
passé au moment de tension addition
c'est superbe
on ne présente pas la vidéo tout de
suite parce que la réponse est dans la
vidéo mais vous vous avez sûrement la
réponse
moi je ferais pas encore mis en images
ont été captées en afrique
non non non non c'est pas là je ne sais
pas bouteflika ne s'est pas la licra
demande c'est pas les creusements une
image d'un avion boeing sol je sais
qu'on avait beaucoup d'image de boeing
mais je pense que d'après moi c'était
pas vraiment c'était pas ça l'essentiel
est la même l'avion était contrôlé par
l'intelligence artificielle parce que ça
joue un jour là les boîtes noires
oui ça pourrait être ça mais c'est pas
ça c'est pas ça c'est beaucoup plus
simple c'est terre à terre
c'est un jeu la semaine qui relie à
l'accident des gens qui pleurent parce
qu'il fera les relations politiques ou
non pas de réaction pour le marché
canadien des canadiens des canadiens
dès les victimes canadiennes quand on
regarde son poste on va prendre mais oui
la tragédie concernant de cette famille
le père la main si l'on prend par an ils
étaient six je crois bien au sein d'une
même famille 18 canadiens sont décédés
alors j'ai toutes les images je dirais
pays pour vous et c'est sur le site de
cible ici j'ai retrouvé sa mère de la
famille de six personnes c'est ça en
voici des images d'au moins 4 je crois
c'est l'âme la mère de famille qui
partait faire découvrir son pays
d'origine à ses enfants et puis voilà
puis emprunte un je pense que c'est
important ça c'est quelqu'un qui de
calgary c'est ça un prof d'université si
je ne me trompe
non c'est pas lui il ressemble aux
professeurs de siège aux pays sort du
niveau excité sas une jeune de l'ouest
canadien national environnement
aujourd'hui nations unies et c'était
vraiment sa passion lui aussi c'était
quelqu'un est intéressé par la passionné
par l'environnement dans cold
britannique
ça brise le coeur et puis ça aussi
c'était beaucoup de gens qui allaient à
la conférence des nations unies sur
l'environnement n'a rien oublié aussi
quelqu'un bien créé deux manches dans le
domaine de l'agriculture suisse et
canada
réguler de marche j'ai pas les détails
la concernant mais on voit derrière elle
des camps de réfugiés
on me camps de réfugiés sur mon
personnel des nations unies
c'est ça puis 18 vix a fait beaucoup de
gens ça je ne fais d'ottawa damoiseaux
stéphanie lacroix je pense
qui rêvait de faire la famille se trouve
qu'ils mère de famille c'est elle qui
est décédé et puis quelqu'un je pars de
la région toronto je pense qu'en fait
terminé avec une image d'un bd sont tous
des canadiens il ya eu une autre
tragédie d'avancé ce qui s'est passé en
nouvelle zélande et semaine selon son
son jules difficile alors nous on parle
d'obsolescence pour les amis j'ai bien
écouté ce pas fini ouais on fait le tour
pour voir combien vrs de boules carrées
70 ok je vous crois pas sur parole moi
j'avais gagné 80 cents je suis un homme
était le premier elle avait gardé ses
boules jeu mais la première n'est pas la
première question je vais pas on a tous
perdus c'était vous avez tout ce que
vous partiez à 70 c'est vendredi en
classe
ouais ouais j'ai raté deux questions bon
non mais j'ai dit non non vous savez
qu'à vous avez radar n'est qu'une
question
bon je vous ai perdu 2,20 bull savoir si
tu avais raté la première question que
tout le monde reste 80 bol il vous reste
quatre ou cinq roulent ils voient santé
qui voit 50 boul
bon alors aussi la dernière question
sociale attention c'est un bon tout le
temps parce que je vous ai apporté comme
cela c'est ce que l'on gagne ou bientôt
10 jetons voilà le sens à boules ça
complique les choses
leur idylle j'attends qu'ils allaient
redonner aux femmes vous les perdez
alors âgé made in tu nous donnes au
début de chaque mission sur 90 100
dollars ouais au patron
alors c'est un des premiers exodes de
sénescence programme et qu'on connaisse
très documenté on avait beaucoup écrit
là-dessus une obsolescence programmée
par le design et la mode donc
l'obsolescence dont on parlait plutôt
esthétique entretenue par une bonne
campagne de publicité dans ce cas-ci de
bonnes campagnes de publicité dites moi
quel la compagnie automobile qui a été
la première au monde à recourir à ce
qu'on appelle l'obsolescence programmée
et ses environs sont en est ce que
c'était fiat environ 100 ans
est ce que c'était de b peugeot est ce
que c'était ses formes
est-ce que cet été gm alors qu'elle est
la première compagnie automobile qui a
dix mois l'offre de l'essence le veulent
un programme dense à quoi paul fort la
régie qui m'a dit de façon milani la
région aussi joué moi je sais ce que je
pourrais être pied sur mars mais
j'allais dire de ce sujet j'avais des
vols avant même que ça sent tellement
évident mais impossible de fiat punto cd
italien fiat
c'est l'italienne s'est éteint le jour
généralement ils sont très très bons
dans la mare il a jonglé vous avez à
fiat
ah bon alors vous perdez 50 boul
les organes la course fier
[Musique]
cjs un symbole son projet je crois bien
je donc savoir la ccl la ford
c'est la fin en fait qu'est ce que je
dis non non je me suis non je suis
désolé vous perdez tout 50 jours oui
c'est non pas que joe cgm parce que
ouais si ford a fait la force de tes
modèles extrêmement durable pendant 19
ans aucun problème ça casse passée
autour de ça pour que ça dure
sauf que par la suite ils ont été
introduits le modèle ah ouais c'est vrai
qu'ils aient rendu l'été le modèle t
aube c'est là où est en partie mais en
fait c'est gm qui dit ah ah ouais ben
avait le vieux modalités là nous voici
on vous offre quelque chose de nouveau
ils ont complètement été chercher une
part du marché qu'à quelques fordaq
apparaît donc cgm qui grâce à bobby cité
s'est dit non
le durable c'est pas bon ça pour vous
c'est pas une valeur dans la publicité
où on vous vend du neuf du modèle ce
nouveau programme et dépendent d'une
compagnie par ces produits pas déplacé
par un autre compagnie je lance un
protêt vous protestez avons envoyé ça au
département c'est alors nations unies le
coude le connu le que naulleau lui
martèle connu le plaisir est là
moi je me suis lancé dans une
généralisation un peu déplacée parce que
généralement les mafieux ne sont pas
dans le secteur automobile comme
première d'école c'est quand même fou
qui a remporté le jeu cette semaine vous
avez le marabout a perdu 50 boul
ok donc alors comment ça je rejoue pas
ce que c'est les deux et si vous pensez
vous regarderez le ruban gagner une
sauce termine ici d'accord merci à
l'année prochaine
j'ai ça ne m'a pas des premiers classés
6e